[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom's night is a rose a kind of
night every night should be a rose a
night so I don't know if you guys
remember but a while back we did a video
about why judgy parrots are the worst
and it was just flooded with comments of
oh my gosh you miss this and this and
this and this and this and there was
enough to make a whole other video so
tonight we're gonna talk about why
judgey parents are still the worst some
more judging of the judge appearance
first relationship status many of you
probably don't know that I started out
as a single mom and it was great I loved
being a single mom
I loved parenting my son just the two of
us but for some reason that's so hard
for other people to grasp I remember
this one incident where I was at the
park and my son was playing and he met
this other little boy his age I met the
little boy's mom she was great we had
very similar parenting styles and when
it came time to leave the park she asked
me about my husband and I told her I
didn't have a husband and she just shut
down immediately it's like people can't
understand that there is happiness in a
family system that's different than
theirs to all the single parents out
there moms dads divorced never married
whatever you are they're plugging along
and doing this parenting thing and
surviving this one's for you and you're
doing great next working mom versus
stay-at-home mom there's this huge
passive-aggressive war that I say all
over Facebook between working moms and
stay-at-home moms the working moms
always say these little snide comments
of almost be nice to just hang around at
home with your kids all day and then the
stay-at-home moms are like oh hey Mae
Pennington males raise their kids I've
been a working mom a stay-at-home mom
and a work from home mom and I've seen
it all and I know they're all equally
difficult as the stand room mom yeah you
get to spend the whole day with your
kids and that's great but then your
whole day is just around kids and I
would wait til the mailman came and be
like hey you want to come in and have a
nice tea do you want to just like talk
about the weather and then as a working
mom there's the guilt that comes with
being a working mom I miss a lot of
parades at school and parties and stuff
like that because they're in the middle
of the day and I can't just leave work
to go there and see it and then come
back so I declare a truce truce this is
what I used to do with my kids when we
would wrestle we'd be like juice when it
was time to end because working moms and
stay-at-home moms have it equally
difficult unless you're a stay-at-home
mom with a nanny and a housekeeper then
just go away don't even talk to me next
blended families I have a friend who has
adopted children and not adopted
children and she's constantly asked by
complete strangers which ones are your
real kids and she has the most perfect
answer to this she'll be like oh you
know this one's a robot this one's
actually a ventriloquist dummy and this
one's one of those really really really
realistic looking AI robots we're in an
age where there are families of all
shapes and sizes and colors and it's not
abnormal like I get comments all the
time on my Instagram about both of my
son's because they do not look alike and
I'm never going to talk about it because
that's my choice and for somebody to
comment asking me about it is extremely
rude and I immediately delete it the
once again the best advice is to keep
your mouth shut and just assume that all
of my children are robots sometimes I
wish my kids were robot
they'd have like sleep button next
binky's also known as pacifiers also
known as mouth plugs for kids apparently
there's this universal age that's too
old to suck on a pacifier according to
every Wyndham stranger who likes to
judge you know I had a friend who has
two daughters and both of them were
really really obsessed with her
pacifiers and once both of them or
toddlers they weren't ready to give them
up but my friend was so stressed because
every time she went out and her
daughter's had a pacifier complete
strangers would come up and say oh I
think old teeth the board haha and so
she ended up cutting all the tips off of
the pacifiers to try to wean them off of
them and but it was a disaster it
backfired on her because she just needed
to wait until her kids were ready so if
you're judging parents for giving their
children pacifiers you're ultimately
judging their child for not being ready
to give up the pacifier and that's weird
like judge adults don't judge kids and
if you're a parent with kids who use a
pacifier and you're judged for their age
just carry an extra pacifier just stick
it in that person's mouth just be like
Shh last junk food you know I spend all
this time judging other judgy parents
for judging parents I never really
talked about the things that I judge for
I judge other parents for feeding their
kids junk food and if I see a mom at the
checkout line in the grocery store and
she has cookies and cake and pie and ice
cream and chicken nuggets and nothing
but junk food on the conveyor belt I'll
judge then I really have to check myself
because I look at my own conveyor belt
at the grocery store and there are like
six pints of ice cream just for me no
man that goes to my kids ultimately I
think with judgy parents need to realize
is that what we're seeing and what we're
judging is the most miniscule part of a
person's life we don't know the whole
story
so we're filling in parts of the big
picture based on what we think the rest
is the way that I can Pat being a judgy
parent is I try to think of the big
picture and I try to see what this
parents potential life could be based on
more than what I'm just seeing but at
the end of the day I'm not perfect and I
still judge but I gave it to myself
because I'm not a
so why is that so hard for other people
just be like me don't be a jerk
I finished it too early I usually have a
little left of my class at the end so
that's all I got for today I'm Hannah
your friendly neighborhood wine mom and
if there's anything we missed again
leave it in the comments we probably
won't make a part three but I love to
read them and as always if there's
anything you'd like me to talk about
leave that in the comments as well in
the meantime I'm gonna go eat some cold
leftover Chinese food judge me all you
want I'm gonna eat it anyway till next
time and that's how it's done kids
[Music]